I know what he's referring to. 1 Peter
3:18-19. And 1st Peter 3:18-19 doesn't
say
that. So let me answer the first part.
Do we have good reason to believe that
when Jesus's physical body was in turn
in the in the tomb, Jesus's human
soul descended into shol had what he
called hell? And this is where it gets
confusing. When we talk about
hell, most people use hell to refer
to the state of the
dead who have died in unbelief. In other
words, if I'm an unbeliever and I die, I
go to hell.
Okay? However, here's where it's going
to get a little confusing. So, I'm going
to try to be as simple as I can.
Hell comes from the word gah, the Greek
word gina. Now guys, you got to pay
attention or I'm going to lose you
here.
Gina refers
to that place quote unquote. I put place
in question marks because it's a
spiritual dimension where unbelievers
will be sent to be
destroyed with their bodies and souls.
Go to Matthew 10:28 if you can.
Matthew 10:28. Okay.
And read it for us. Okay.
Okay. And by the way, in in uh in Arabic
would be Jannam, right? Janam. Yes.
Yeah. So, in the Greek it's gina, where
they'll tell you comes from the Hebrew
words, you know, valley of Hanam. But
anyway, read Matthew 10:20. What gina,
which is typically translated as hell,
refers to fear not them which kill the
body, but are not able to kill the soul,
but rather fear him which is able to
destroy both body and soul in hell. So
the word hell here is the word gimna.
That's the place where unbelievers will
be sent to be
destroyed both with their bodies and
souls. Body and
soul. When we talk about unbelievers
that have died going to a place of
torment awaiting the day of judgment,
the word there in the Greek is hades.
Hades hades. And in Hebrew it's
shades
shol after Christ. Pay attention after
Christ is that dimension where
unbelievers are
sent in their souls in their spirits
devoid of their bodies because they go
there when they die. So when they die,
physical body returns to the dust. But
their souls, their spirits go to Hades,
Hades,
Shol. That is different from
ge. Okay, that is different from
gehina. Okay, ge is where your body and
soul will be sent to be destroyed. Now
someone's saying, what does destroy
mean? Well, you have people saying
annihilated. Others say everlasting
destruction. I'm simply using this
language of scripture, everlasting
destruction. 2 Thessalonians chapter 1 7
to 10, specifically verse 9. But we'll
get there in a minute. So there
are two words that are translated
typically as hell. Hades had Hebrew sh
and gina. They're not the same.
Gaha
guehana is the place where unbelievers
will be
destroyed both in their
bodies with their souls soul and body.
Everyone got
that? Hades, Hades, Sh is that
dimension, that place
where the souls, the spirits of
unbelievers go to be tormented when they
physically die. So their bodies don't go
there. Their bodies return to the dust.
Their souls go there. And then at the
day of resurrection, their bodies are
raised. Their souls are united. They
stand before God in judgment. Then they
are sent to Gehenna hell, both with
their bodies and souls intact. Everyone
got
that? If everyone got that, I have to
add a further
element. Hades after Christ, after
Christ's death, resurrection, ascension.
Hades sh is now the place where only
unbelievers go to. Prior to Christ,
before Christ's death, resurrection,
ascension, this place called Hades, Sh
was the place where all the dead went,
righteous and the wicked. But the
difference is there was a place in Hades
where the righteous would go, but they
would be in peace and rest and they
would not experience torment. So imagine
Hades has two compartments.
One compartment for unbelievers and
there they're tormented. The other
compartment in the same dimension for
believers and there they're waiting in
peace and rest and bliss until Jesus
comes and takes their souls and spirits
into God's heavenly abode where God the
Father appears visibly where the angels
are. That only took place after Jesus's
death, resurrection, and ascension.
Everyone got it? Let me give a moment to
see if they got it so then I can answer
the question. I see a few comments here
that seem to uh indicate that they did
catch that. So,
okay.
So, everyone got it? That's good. So,
now with that in the background, where
did Jesus go when he physically died?
Well, his human soul, his human spirit
went to Hades. Sh what we call hell.
Why did he go there? Because the
righteous dead were there in a state of
bliss and peace awaiting the Lord to
come and lead them out of that place and
bring them into the father's heavenly
presence. Now, where do we find that
Jesus went to Hades shol? Go to Acts 2,
read 29-32.
Acts 2 29:32.
Okay.
Now, Peter quotes a psalm of David,
Psalm 16:8-11, where David talks about
God's holy one being rescued from shol
and his body not corrupting. And then
Peter says, David wasn't talking about
himself because David has been dead for
a thousand years and his tomb is with
us. So, who was David talking about?
Read Acts 29:32.
says,"Men and brethren, let me freely
speak unto you of the patriarch David,
that he is both dead and buried, and his
supplicer is with us unto this
day." Therefore, being a prophet, and
knowing that
God had sworn with an oath to him that
the fruit of his loins, according to the
flesh, he would raise up Christ to sit
on his throne. He seeing this before
spake of the resurrection of Christ that
his soul was not left in hell neither
did his flesh see corruption. Where did
his human soul go when he died? Did was
not left in hell. So where did his human
soul go? Hell. Yeah. But what word is
it? It's not gehenna. It's hades. Hades.
Okay. So Jesus's soul, not his flesh,
went to Hades, Shol, but his flesh was
in the tomb. And so his flesh did not
corrupt because his soul came out of
Hades and re-entered his body and he
resurrected his body, made his body of
flesh, immortal. Because 32 says what?
This Jesus hath God raised up whereof we
all are witnesses. Wow. Now, to further
confirm that Jesus went to Hades, Shol,
let me show you something that's going
to be mind-blowing. Okay? When Jesus
confronts the demoniacs, the legion,
yes, go to Luke 8:31. Notice what they
tell Jesus. Luke 8:31. Luke 8:31. Okay.
They besought him that he would not
command them to go out into the deep.
Now, the word deep is abuso.
It's also the bottomless pit, the
abyss. The Greek word is abuso, meaning
the pit. The bottomless pit, the
abyss. Okay? You know why that's
important? You have an idea why that's
important? Because in Revelation chapter
9 verses 111 it says a star came down
from
heaven and there was an angel who was
given the key to the bottomless pit the
abuso and this star this angel who's the
king of this place the deep the abuso
the abyss his name is Abaden Apolon Abad
in Hebrew Apaleon in Greek and he opened
the shaft to the abyss and demons came
out that had tails like scorpions and
sharp teeth and hair like women to
torment mankind for five
months. So these demons didn't want to
go there, right? Mhm. And guess who else
is going to be in the abyss? In
Revelation 20:es 1-3, it says, "Satan
will be bound in chains in the abyss, in
the deep, in the bottomless pit for a
thousand years." It's the same word.
Wow. Revelation 20 verse 1 and 3. So you
see what the abyss is the deep the
bottom spit where the
demons are
constrained imprisoned and where Satan
will be constrained and imprisoned for a
thousand years. Right?
Guess where Jesus went. Go to Romans 10
6-7. Romans 10 6 to7. Guess where Jesus
went?
Almost 10. 6 to
7. Read where Jesus went. But the
righteousness which is of faith speaketh
on this wise. Say not in your heart, who
shall ascend to heaven? That is to bring
Christ down from above. Or who shall
ascend? Into the deep. That is to bring
Christ up from the dead. Wait, Jesus
went where? To the deep. That's the same
word in Luke 8:31 where the demon said,
"Don't send us there." Wow.
So Jesus descended when he died. Where?
Where did his soul go to?
And I went to Hades and it also went to
the are these the same place? Well, it
it will be in the same realm. It just
may be different compartments, different
different realms of the same location.
Right. Okay. So Jesus went to the deep.
The word is abuso, the bottomless pit,
where Satan will be bound and where
demons are constrained. That's where
Jesus went for three days. Wow. Now, he
didn't go there to be tormented or
tortured. He went there to show his
victory over the kingdom of darkness and
to show unbelievers what they lost by
refusing to believe the gospel that was
preached to them and to bring out the
souls of the righteous Abraham, Isaac,
and Jacob, and ascend with them into
God's heavenly abode. You led captivity
captive. Yep.
Wow. Wow. Thank you. That's answer
Emily's question. Emily was wondering
when Samuel's spirit spoke to Saul.
That's a good question. Tomorrow you and
your children will be with me. Well,
wait. Saul is an unbeliever. How's he
going to be with Samuel? Because they
all went there. Samuel went there and
Saul went there, but Samuel was in a
state of peace and rest. And Saul would
have been in a place of torment just
like the rich man and Lazarus. Yes. In
Luke 16
19-31, the rich man died and he was
buried and he found his soul in Hades.
The word is had which the King James
says hell. And he was in torment and he
could see a far off Abraham and Lazarus.
But Abraham, Lazarus were in a state of
peace and rest. So they could see each
other because in the same realm, but
there was a gulf. They couldn't cross
over to each other. Luke 16 19- 26.
Wow. Thank you for that, man. That's
awesome, man.